my name is Tamara chambers
welcome to the last supper because I'm
Jesus both an enthusiastic live and
sarcastic certain expectation I want to
see that you'll see the exact movie yes
the trailer promised us what we saw yeah
I want to say that like I said this in
the theater if any other actor I think
was cast in the role that Dwayne the
rock Johnson was casted I wouldn't have
been excited and he's so delivered he
was great in it talking about Chris
Pratt could have carried it smells he's
ridiculously charming and his whole
goddamn family and this is ridiculous
she just vanished somewhere after the
90s and then all of a sudden it's like
yeah the failure was incredibly cast but
like my god he was so charming and so
believable and I just loved the fuck out
of every mole of to the fuck out of
there
[Laughter]
it's one part cuz I heard everyone else
kind of laughing at this birth there's
one part where he was a little weird and
that's like you know they got his
daughter big shock and they're like you
know I'm gonna get in this room or else
we're gonna kill your daughter the bunch
of things bleeding and everything
comfy airplane - sad music oh that the
first day of shooting did they not tell
him oh no at this point in the movie
you've been beaten to death you should
be like really bummed right now about
everything else yeah I thought was said
like you said like just so friggin
charming is there's so many moments
where people just like we all laughed
and the people behind this left and
there are so many moans were random
people in the audience call that it's
still I was still like fuck oh no oh God
ah like I was still looking nervous
about happening yeah I was invested in
this family I was legitimately flinching
whenever something slipped if someone
had to cross through like you know
they'd do the thing with us like the
board and somebody had to walk across
and they'd die if you put together of
like you go in knowing it's gonna be
some bullshit but also it's like I'm
still here for when I was in college I
saw the premiere of the towering inferno
which was the air sauce die hard we've
all watched MacGyver on TV yeah I put
those three together and there you go it
does not work that way you can't just
wrap your hands and duct tape but now
you're spider-man helps it stick to the
windows but then he's sliding down the
rope with his duct tape and I'm like
wait I just stuck to a company with Rob
just got through me for a little bit but
I'm glad did is that the cut the kind of
dumb this is I say it's something Amanda
okay I kind of blow on the lines of like
the expendables where it's like it knows
what it's doing but it's not like
Expendables 2 or 3 where it's super
winking at you and it's not a one-liner
movie it's not rampage like it legit
like it acts like it's taking it so
seriously like and they're all acting
seriously like they're in the real movie
but the environment what's going on is
obviously stupid but they take it
seriously and so you are more invested
in this you know dumb but super enjoy
Bobby died yeah yeah but they do we can
not chat you a little bit with the lines
and straight delivery like the rock just
flat-out says this is stupid but you
know what I mean we're a lot of movies
like well like expect like the
expendable sequels there be a lot more
one-liner
yeah we're and they don't do that I'm
gladly because it actually pulls you in
a lot like recently speaking like you
just said rampage like which is a very
comparable film I feel like I feel like
it's the way the rock Johnson it's it's
like a cheesy action film but you're
right it's like it's less like
in-your-face like it is more grounded
yet which is my fate yeah but this was
so much grounded as a movie can be where
would are we like his leg falls off and
he grabs on to that and like the lady
behind me shouted bullshit
or a magic button puts out 96 floors on
[Music]
bullshit the partner with her was like
yeah but it's Dwayne the rock Johnson
where it's the big scene the poster
where he's jumping from the crane onto
the building the big jump and she goes
oh no and he just goes it's the rock I
also enjoyed how she the wife was such a
badass yeah like Dwayne was like
obviously the clear badass star of this
movie but also the wife was like
hey she's amazing negative
every character this this is no reason
why brides of 80s movies every character
stuck out yeah there was not a single
character where I'm just like that could
have been anybody I'm like no they all
were very distinct the one thing I was a
little upset has a little let down by
you that there's like some sort of
assassin they're worse earrings because
of course we're earrings to a heist and
you know like GG chasers this teasers
the rock steals this thing from him he's
costume and they're all shooting and all
her like companions are kidding down the
running away she's just walking away
everybody grinder high heels yeah that's
cool yeah she's got like a cool kind of
haircut and it's just like well okay man
I can't wait for the roads can go Walt I
do like her and to see like the cheesy
speech she's gonna give and then it's
like they have her go up against the
wife with in a cool action see but it's
like okay but I want to see the rock go
up against obviously the rocks would be
you know it's gonna be the first big
star and I think the second biggest art
is that building that building's amazing
I do this yeah they would just scan hump
it was funny when they're going across
the water in the beginning I turned to
rob and I said I failed into that very
important when I was over there in Hong
Kong and I'm look it is beautiful the
Boxer Rebellion yes they're the Hong
Kong looks beautiful but they fit this
thing in from all these different angle
and what sits on fire it looks like a
giant flaming penis if I had only one
complaint about this movie it said it
feels like a lost swartz and Egger
script from like 1987 yeah and I'm just
like us is so like it like one of those
80s movies like commando or even films
like die hard yeah this so needed to be
a hard r2 because I'm like it just would
have made it perfect just it was a
little more violent a little more hungry
I'm half in half because I think there's
so many cool death scenes that they then
cut away from but I never step for the
fun
which is crazy gookju of the movie is
the it's based on the emotion for the
family though and I do feel like if it
was a little more Gloria would have
taken that sentimentality a little bit
out I'm at oh no I mean it can be done
it is trickier but I feel like there's
surprisingly a lot of heart to this
movie I feel like I understand what
you're saying because that would have
been really cool because it was already
such like high intensity that like to
add that would have been awesome it just
made a perfect I had a good joke I
didn't feel like I felt like satisfied
with what you got like I was going into
it thinking like I'll enjoy it
I really love the rock that's still like
I'm gonna enjoy it but like I enjoyed it
more than I thought music yeah it was
all that I hoped for yeah but nothing
more like that's where I wanted the hard
are where my boss is all I would hope
they would be but I wanted them well
let's just stay oh well ok so I think my
final thoughts on this is just that I I
just love the rock so much he's a
treasure he says it's treasure and I
love everything that he's in we were
just talking about the new Jumanji I
really enjoyed rampage this is great I
feel like all of these scripts well do
moderately good but like I feel like I
don't know rampage in this especially
could have been such a duds and not that
he was the one that led it to success
but he's just really great he's a big
part he's a big puzzle piece in it he is
very smart when he chooses his scripts
like he knows how to approach a project
and kind of you know go with the flow of
it well thank you so much for seeing
this thank you so much for watching I'll
see you all next week
[Music]
you